Speaker 1: So we had today something happen,
which happens every couple of months, which
is at the very, very last second a guest no
shows cancels on us and that's a really sad
thing or happy, depending on your perspective,
because instead we'll get to hear from a few
people in our audience right now via discord.
The discord is at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
It's a great discord.
It's a good discord, and we love it.
Let's go first just to see what's on folks
minds, let's go to Desmond from South Carolina.
Desmond, you were on the air.
What's going on?
Speaker 3: Well, can you guess?
I can go on.
David, I really appreciate your show.
Haven't tuned in recently, but let me catch
my breath, please.
All right, so I've been noticing a lot with
conservative friends and family around me.
Speaker 1: Where you're running a marathon
there, Desmond?
Speaker 3: No, I mean, this is the first time
for me.
Gotcha, gotcha.
You're doing great.
I appreciate it.
I went out to eat with my grandma conservative.
And we were noticing how here in South Carolina,
there's a lot of places that are there, like
hiring and.
And some places are like.
My grandmother was saying, oh, it's because
all these people are too lazy, because all
they're getting is welfare and right.
Unemployment, and it just maybe it triggered
a thing in me that made me realize, well,
you know, an economics class, this is kind
of like a perfect moment to raise minimum
wage.
And I don't get why really talking about that
kind of basic economic stuff.
Well, because
Speaker 1: a lot of people and listen, this
is conservatives and liberals.
Everybody does this to some degree.
You identify a symptom and then you say it's
a symptom that proves my politics are the
right ones.
So on the left, people see, hey, there's jobs
remaining unfilled.
It's because the wages are too low.
Raise the minimum wage.
Why?
Because the left already wants to raise the
minimum wage.
On the other hand, the right, which doesn't
want to raise the minimum wage but wants to
end welfare, sees jobs going unfilled.
And they say, well, you've got to reduce welfare.
It's too cushy to stay at home.
You know, the truth is we're in kind of a
unique situation right now because of the
pandemic where enhanced unemployment has made
it so that there are people who otherwise
would have no choice but to go and get a job,
who have been able to stay on unemployment,
earning a little more than they normally would.
It's ending in September.
And as I've said before, most people want
to work.
Most people derive meaning from being involved
in something and not just from sitting at
home.
Any welfare system will have free riders,
but if it's properly calibrated, you don't
have to worry about that.
I think this is going to resolve itself in
September, October, November.
Speaker 3: OK, yeah, I didn't know about all
those ending in September.
It was interesting to me because I noticed
the unemployment numbers getting slowly back
down to that four percent.
But still, like and I notice other states
actually, when I looked into it, are actually
resolving the issue quite well, where they
easily had the they just adapt and they're
like, OK, well, we'll pay you more.
But there's a lot of places here, even like
bigger businesses, like dealerships are having
troubles hiring people because our our minimum
wage in South Carolina is seven.
Twenty five, so.
Speaker 1: Right.
Yeah, I think that this is going to look very
different in October.
Speaker 3: OK, I mean, I appreciate it, David.
All right,
Speaker 1: thanks.
There's been great call from South Carolina.
Love it.